Oh Oh God runway you want to be on my
team or do you want a car go I'll be on
Bob's team I'll be on Bob's team okay
we're in the same helicopter yeah yeah
imma die together right yeah don't throw
them but we have a memory about it
I don't like it I will not have whirring
in my helicopter no we're not worried
cuz I'm on the the you know mounted
camera this camera yeah okay
we're hovering above the suspension
bridge coming my darkest cover and then
I'm gonna swipe you out of this guy just
you watch oh no I'm gonna do a dust ball
oh so that you get bit bulkier hardly to
miss it Oh Bobby you ready over here
smokey but I'm almost okay you guys
ready ready let's do this where all of
you get in the car I'll pick you up and
then I'll drop you
rocket you are never or entire life
going to successfully pick up a car with
that thing up shut up shut up see you
try I'm I'm not saying don't but this is
not good yeah man I got whose car am I
getting into putting I got ever oh I've
got a two-seater but if you guys find a
four-seater we probably need you know
three three of us in the guard
oh all the water yeah where where did
you [ __ ] her school what's going on here
what
shopping [ __ ] go wait Bobby gonna be
right there
where are my other trucks going okay Bob
no yeah
oh my guy I have stars so if you could
oh yeah
see you later trying I'm trying Oh
triumphs Bobby sure you try it
trying Bob just kill him boy get our own
vehicle I'm trying okay
coming in for the kill Matt downs i
headl rocket how do i deploy my hook
oh do that um wait are they just women
number pad baby I think I got I think I
got a left arrow or something
we know you have stars I got I don't
know what happened I got it
Bob okay I'm almost there Oh mark I got
the headset oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
ah goddamn okay that's only two got it
you can do it you can do it I have faith
that you wait I'm help okay my hooks
down so sound take it yeah grab hook
lock up I got [ __ ] right to your right a
little to your right right right come on
oh that's a lot of [ __ ] you do it I can
do it
I got wait wait wait wait wait wait [ __ ]
your wife [ __ ] you Wade gonna take it I
don't like hooking eyes anymore all
right oh [ __ ] oh right there at me hurt
any more that's it oh my god Oh sinker
right there I was so close I was so
close
oh man that was awesome actually
thanks thanks man thanks thanks bro I
appreciate your input bro thanks man
thanks
oh my god cops are you I could sit why
are there so many cops everywhere I may
have killed a lot of them men to the
press good publishing then and then wait
ruined it so although stops to Richard
thanks that's impossible I got spooked
Wade all right my stomach hurts a little
bit I scream ha ha
else's what now open road guys are too
funny haha rotting happened on my screen
I didn't just make that sound for no
reason that you wait
yeah it's up oh we just did a 360 man
yeah noscope hey buddy how's it going
hey protip it's this way
Oh bro time are we held the airport
again yeah gonna go try getting up with
some more helmet rappers sweet okay I
wish it was a nighttime in the game
the thing that school in this game is
you can get um jet skis if you go to the
pier which are free oh yeah holy I'm
scared of it
Oh Center I'm failed how much better
could I do man I'll see you can ride the
roller coaster cares
you can JIT [ __ ] [ __ ] I can try and
shoot your friends off the road you
build there's a ramp on the other side
way that's why I told you to go the
other way
wait over here I mean let me let me ride
passenger in that one bad shotgun mark
hurry up I got some stars cos the clock
sideways I'm Anders Ram boom it's the
dumpster ramp here I'll come hover over
it hey the rest wrap wait think the
track just hit yeah it's right here dick
[ __ ] you cop ok I'm right here sits
right underneath me there's a ramp ok
I'll see if I'm just gonna go don't stir
let's go meow go the skip whoa
Oh get up there you go oh [ __ ] it red
cups
choppers my [ __ ] holy [ __ ] the police
chopper just like swooped us I'm a
military chopper you [ __ ] what do you
mean you want me to hit him try to join
me to beat him up get out of there Jack
help I got him
[ __ ] worried about a dude ah subtour
no problem
how's it going wid ya
should I did nice put into the sky
Whizzer winds up I see wait it winds up
sure that's not the carnival yeah yeah
go to the carnival we should just work
off that cuz then if we die with Sporto
oh I'm on the pier on the pier yeah
gotta hear ya what's the real name of
that PA how do I shoot that guy I want
to shoot can't you I don't have a gun
I've never had a gun I don't have any
guns I'm just a guy with no guns that's
we should have helped you figure that
out huh
yeah whatever though that's all good
I'm cool all such good friends in this
video game ah the share tanks and
whatever it's for the carnival you know
doc thank you for the king
ah yeah sure see you here you will you
have to get a jet I thanked you
instantly uh-huh yeah exactly
likes friends would ha ha ha ha ha hey
you see you see get up today should
alarm legolas yeah exactly that's it
that's it wait you are so getting shot
out of the sky
Oh directly dr. Jack exactly these
poppers just following up
listen yeah yeah well they give up they
turned away don't give me that Silk'n
chopper are you all right get [ __ ]
dare the roller coaster dare wait um
maybe the roller coaster buck you wait
Wow jack delivers on his promises and I
am like a laughs see that timely
references man I did it what are you
talking about I love Lord of the Rings
I love Lord of the Thrones uh oh yeah I
gotten out early hello heart of the
future my end yes
oh I kill my cell I get care the hello
Josie now fall for me now we could have
a relaxing time at the pier
hey Dai do I need to pick anyone up I've
got the Chinook it's still alive I got a
quad believe we'd what yeah it's still
alive
got the Chinook whoa willow how do they
explode Bob out of it
I'll figure out it happened place me up
with your blade you dick oh and then is
a delayed wait wait wait wait I was
trying to kill Jackie [ __ ] oh can you
help how it deserves die tanners oh well
I did that's me Jack also deserves to
die don't spare Jack no I would never
oh this is working out it's probably
that's it Jack's in my car not all I
have to do is fly normally and probably
we're gonna go sorry mark I'm out I
seemed it seems to be broken
I don't think welding is working hmm oh
yeah baby good okay
yeah wait now is there that was for
Hilux I've got guns out have no guns out
so who wants to play the game of ride
the roller coaster and kill each other
while they're riding the roller coaster
your archive guy comes on me for some
[ __ ] reason and partly herbai
archenemy sounds about right job mark
practice Holly I'm just I'm trying to
die there you go come here everyone come
to me no I did not want to see this car
Oh Jack wait
where's mark [ __ ] um are there a but I'm
responding
ma'am my guys not in shape he cannot run
my guys been hitting Krispy Kreme ever
too much yeah up on people that's the
thing you guys with Bob I'll need you to
wear well do most right wants to ride
the roller coaster nuanced tomorrow I'm
a-comin I wanna ride the roller coaster
this is the exit [ __ ] me [ __ ] okay
here we go
I should be [ __ ] okay can I get on this
quad bikes I'm
in okay you getting it I'm gonna come
get on I'm gonna do the murdering are
you guys gonna yeah yeah to get it mark
oh we have to have to like push yeah I
push T why were you yeah hi getting in
you have to push left the d-pad wade
there you go Bobby like that isn't my
finger
we're right here Jack how do we make it
go push right on the okay I'm getting
getting getting good oh yeah all right
everyone should be on Oh Oh God like get
away wait I think I might have gotten
away I think about it got away with I
think rights to running around oh wait
oh that nasty get all that nasty you
can't kick me I'm the gingerbread man
and why is there a screaming meter you
you can on the console versions you have
a mic built into your controller if you
scrape into it you earn screaming points
or whatever that's so stupid are you at
Mark and I right now oh I'd try to shoot
you a ferris wheel I'm done I'm done I'm
done
rides over right over right over I don't
know I don't know if it's over until you
get off don't do it I'm gonna get off I
can't shoot you anyway you can't kill
them on the roller coaster
you can't guy to know that you just have
done it yeah you suck but it wouldn't
let me pull the trigger well once you
laid since I don't have a gun I'll just
keep riding on it so you guys try to
shoot me I don't know how to get on it
won't let me maybe you can't get out
when you have stars wait you get on the
roller coaster Oh
I'm just I'm riding again
I'm adding a good high word going are
you doing back there feel good are you
doing this yeah check yo my guys I love
you guys at the top no I get dead
I can't I kill you don't know where he
is